to be able to code some deep learning
model in Karis using the tensorflow as a
back-end and to implement it transfer
learning curves which I added at the end
because I think is very practical for
you to know that this is out there and
not for you to try to reinvent the wheel
so I think we are more or less ok but
this it's gonna go this way so each of
them is one of the notebooks so just as
a curiosity who already knows what deep
learning is oh ok so yeah thank you know
and who has already programmed some some
something with it ok so yeah you were
just here around the thing in the street
and I came in ok good but maybe I can
give you some extra some extra things
that you can learn and of course you can
always ask sort of an advanced question
and I will try to transfer
okay so for those of you that don't know
deep learning or I also see sometimes
people that don't know deep learning but
don't know sort of the history of it
where you come from who are the pioneers
and I think that's also very important
to see who to follow what blocks maybe
to search and stuff so that's the idea
of deep learning comes from the the
artificial neuron neuron which came from
really 1940s or 1950s already and then
it has been revolution in the last I
will say two decades with the
introduction especially well that will
be three decades in 1986 of
backpropagation by Geoffrey Hinton so I
will say he's the father of deep
learning if you don't know you should
search him because he's everywhere so I
would say something like this would be
more of the one in black will be one of
the most important so I think especially
this one in 1986 the introduction of baa
propagation and then now you can train
these neural networks there are other
ways to train them but this one really
improved the performance and that's one
show especially in 2012 that's that's
where I think the break the breakthrough
came in so there's this competition
which is called imagenet so it's open to
the public every year and there's just
made a model and then you get some
accuracy score and when Alex Ned was
into was introduced it blew away all the
other type of models which were not
based on deep learning and that's where
people started noticing and then
Microsoft Google started grabbing the
heads of these departments and
universities like young laocoon like
Java Hinton itself to lead their their
departments in AI in 2014 this is of
course very new but this a sort of a
revolutionary idea what is called
generative adversarial networks
I won't talked about them if you submit
a question and I get enough votes in it
I will address that idea at the end and
then 2015 some clear sort of
breakthroughs of okay and you know we're
beating a human being if human
actually capabilities and I will say it
became sort of mainstream and worldwide
this 2016 alphago I think might be sort
of a just a news kind of a click big
thing of course the algorithm is
extremely complicated but it really
makes a breakthrough for the layman to
tune ok now have to pay attention to it
and especially Korea for example these
the revolutionize the country because
they are very into the game of of God
yeah
and youngly cool so he leads the AI
research for Facebook and was one of the
inventors of the convolutional neural
networks and he said you know this idea
for generated adversarial networks
introduced in 2014 is the best idea so
far in the last decade and it is really
really thinking outside the box because
it allows us to do something that we
were not able to do before which is sort
of penalize or have a sense of a loss
function for something that we as humans
cannot identify ok so what is a deep
neural network so basically is a
artificial representation of the way our
neurons work right so they have some
connections to one to each other they
have certain current that flows from one
to another and then they can shut or not
so we have the concept of layers
input/output so sort of a translation
like that so that's a feed-forward
neural network there are many many types
we're gonna see a bit more and then one
description basically is just
translating that into this artificial
neuron where you have where you have so
some inputs that come from other neurons
then you have here some non-linearity
that transforms this input into some
outputs and then this output basically
connects to other ones right that's
that's the basic ideas I think it's very
easy to understand it's nothing
complicated so the components of it and
I think everybody I guess knows these
names by now is that the input layer
which is basically you
features or whatever you decided that to
be it can be their pixels of an image
can be also can be already features that
you you made with your data then you
have a concept of hidden layers which
are the layers that sort of do the sort
of calculation or their mimic then the
nonlinear function that represents the
relationship between your inputs and the
output that you want to get and then you
have basically the output layer and that
basically is okay I want to let's say do
a classifier of binary I don't know good
or bad or sentiment classification
something like that so that will be just
one run right but then it will have for
example a classification now at
different classes let's say ten okay
then there will be ten runs there and
it's it sounds very easy to say but once
you get to it you need to understand
what you want to get and how to relate
that for example if I tell you okay
which which activation function do you
use when you when you and your output
layer for different categories for ten
categories it's the same that you use
when you do binary no it's not the same
so which one it is okay and then so it
has some relation so we're gonna see a
bit about that a bit more concrete no
artificial neuron these are more or less
the components so you have certain
weights so that basically mimics the
connections between different neurons
can be strong connections or or not so
strong connections then once they get
here in this case you sum them and then
you apply a non-linearity see these
non-linearity is called the activation
function which the most famous one
nowadays Israel ooh so rectified linear
units and do you also have others like
hyperbolic tangents as well and other
ones okay so what is the idea about
these layers so the idea is that the
layers learn hierarchical feature
representations so that means if I'm
going to recognize the face for example
so I start by recognizing shapes
lines and then I start recognizing maybe
circles and then maybe these circles
together capture the eyes or the ear or
the mouth so you have certain schematic
representation that you sort of they
look more like your target that you want
to identify in this case so there are a
bunch a neural networks a bunch like if
you google normally people will know
just a few because those are the ones
that that sort of outperform everything
else but there are a lot of them in
these today we're gonna see fully
connected and convolutional ones but for
example and some other in some other
trainings I also give a recurrent long
short term memory a gated recurrent unit
I won't talk about them but again if you
submit a question then I can maybe say
something in two minutes or something
like that there are a lot I don't know
them all I know I know them by name but
not like specifically some of them are
actually quite old okay so what is the
typical flow for implementing this new
deep neural networks so let's take this
example so in this example we have two
inputs we have the first hidden layer
made of three hidden units then we have
connected to two hidden units and then
we have a single one so this can be some
sort of regression or can be is also
some sort of classification depends on
the function that you put on your output
layer okay so what happens is that so
the input goes and gets multiplied by
these weights right so at the beginning
these weights are randomized and then
they create this sort of the input for
the first unit of the first hidden layer
okay so and it's represented more or
less by this function that you have here
and then you continue and you propagate
forward so you would do this for every
or every neuron in the network and you
propel it forward until you reach the
end once you reach the end and you call
it you have your lost function you will
be able to say okay this is the error
that I have right this can be the
classification
if you have for example generated
adversarial networks that was completely
different but if you have sort of a
regression that you want to apply that
can also be done but then that would be
maybe r-squared or something like this
so yeah ad you have your and now comes
the backpropagation which is the 1986 so
that Delta that error now you want to
calculate that error for each of the
neurons in your network why do you want
to do that because then you can
calculate the gradient of that error
which will point you then to the create
direction that your weight should move
that's basically it so in this case for
example this would be the the error
propagated to the neuron for oh sorry
and the same thing but of course because
there are more connections every time
then it gets a bit more involved right
and you can imagine if it gets this gets
really a wide for example and deep these
basically gets really really a sort of
complicated in the sense of how the
dependencies are throughout the network
and then you go all the way back and
then you calculate the derivative or the
gradients in this case for that specific
weight and then basically you apply what
we all know from linear regression for
example this basically the the
optimization rule you have you have your
derivative over your last function that
you propagated all the way back so for
that a specific neuron and you basically
then add certain coefficient that will
be the learning rate we all know that
from linear regression and then you
basically adapt your weight and that's
it and then you do it for each one okay
so now if you see here there is a lot of
dependencies right because the
penalisation of the weight for let's say
that connect to neuron one will depend
on the other weights for example from
from neuron four or four nine five yeah
so far so good so how do we actually
calculate this so actually we calculate
this by using the what is called the
chain rule which is sort of a basic
way to calculate derivatives are
dependent on other another functions and
there are different ways to do this one
of the ways is to do this this numerical
approximation that if everybody took a
bit of calculus I guess that was the
first equation and you were like what
what is this H and why does it limit to
zero but anyway so that's one way which
is really expensive and it's also prone
to error because what I just said so
normally you will see a limit there
limit I forgot it so sorry for that for
those mathematicians here so limit to
have H going to zero but then it's a
computer right so what does it mean what
does it mean does H Linda's you watch
the actual value I'm gonna put there
that's it it turns difficult and I've
done it myself during my PhD and yeah
you don't want to do that okay so
instead of that you have what is causing
symbolic differentiation symbolic
differentiation means that you have the
actual function that is the derivative
so for example if my function is I don't
know X for example I don't go and do X
plus h sorry X minus X minus H divided
by H instead of say well is one so you
declare it somewhere else that the
derivative of that function is 1 so it's
symbolic so what that allows what that
allows us to do is that we don't need to
do this numerical approximation and it's
much faster so that's why for example
tensorflow does so if you go into the
tensor flow source code every layer that
you're gonna find their activation
function that derivative is defined
you're gonna find it because it uses
this because if not it will take forever
and it's also prone to error for what I
just said
so there are some what I what I will say
but maybe somebody that is more expert
than me will say no it's because of this
or that I think there's some sort of
conventions so for example when you have
the relu the derivative if you know that
relu the relu looks like this goes like
this until 0 and then it goes like that
ok so what's the problem with the
derivative of that
exactly so right so okay now you okay
how do you do it right so if you go to
the tensorflow code there's an if of
course right so to my to my physics is
mathematical background is like but it
is and it's a convention you can see it
there okay
so so you can find it and that's why
it's a bit fast much faster than you
could do numerical computation and the
issue is that if you evaluate the
derivative from zero you have to you
have to make a choice so they make a
choice
apparently not
probably like I said probably someone
that actually implemented this will will
let you know more you can ask them in
github of course maybe there's already
wonder but no apparently it's not an
issue and it's not the only one it's not
the only function that does that okay so
how these back propagation so everybody
good with about procreation more or less
huh you get it back you propagate your
errors they calculate the derivative and
then you move okay so how these these
back propagation and actually works so
first of all like I said well you need
to define these errors right so then for
that you can define your lot you have to
define your last function so then you
can differentiate the last function
because if not how do you know what the
error is if you haven't defined
basically okay you know it's R squared
or is a binary curse and sorry I cut the
Oracle's across entropy or binary
whatever you want so that's the first
thing and there are a bunch in already
in chaos then for that and then the next
thing is you're gonna have to define
your optimizer how am I going to run the
gradient descent right from linear
regression we know is to caste great in
the sense or great in the central itself
right great descent if we know yeah it's
taking basically all the data and you do
once Optima once the optimization step
for all the data stochastic great in the
sense says okay we're gonna use batches
right and then
for each of the batch I do a step and I
move right that's why it's a bit more
six tagging if you if you see a de los
curve so but there are other ones so we
have several like stochastic rate ascent
with momentum other grad rmsprop that
works well especially for recurrent
neural networks Adam which I will say
it's more or less the de facto right now
to use the things also to the faulting
carers so all of these I won't go
specifically because we have a little
time but all of these is just is the
stochastic agree and it sends the same
rule but it adds a bit of momentum to
the search so when you do get stochastic
gradient descent or Gary in the sense
what you actually are doing you have a
surface and you're trying to find the
minimum of that surface and what it's
doing is moving and it's checking is
this lower than that and then it moves
this is lower than the other one
and then it moves to that point and
stuff like that right it continues okay
so but what this what this actually
potentially can can do to you is that
you get stuck right around a valley so
when you add a momentum to it it's more
like searching with a bicycle so you
have a downhill you're going with your
bicycle and you find sort of the valley
and you continue a bit more and no no it
still goes up okay then I'll go back but
maybe it goes it has the momentum enough
to cross this this local minimum and
then it finds maybe the other one yeah
all of these bear are under this
principle just the way they implement
momentum that's the thing that is
different good so okay so and the only
words I know okay so this is a some
example of that so for example you can
see especially a thing in the picture on
your right you can see the difference
right and that those those surfaces are
special surfaces that are made to tests
this sort of minimization of functions
even before I knew deep learning
knew this the other one which is we call
it in Mexico the horse settle says
because it has this this yeah of course
that's not how we call it in Spanish but
yeah that's that's that's basically the
translation last year a caballo I think
it's okay so so you see the difference
right so you can get stuck and
especially for surfaces that are very
complicated that's a big issue because
you're gonna have a lot of bumps so a
surface where you have I don't know 20
layers and then each of the layer has 30
units so that means I don't know you're
gonna have and yet then you have some
maybe convolutions maybe you end up with
3000 weights so that means 3000
dimensions on this surface is very proud
to have local minima yeah so it's very
important so in my opinion never use a
stochastic gradient descent I think I
will submit the ticket in character they
should remove it or something now okay
so okay so that's brain is how you train
them so I also I think this is a very
important slide especially for people
coming because say you see and they get
impressed and you go to the starts and
these guys using deep learning why am I
not using it as well and it's not for
everything at least in my experience
okay so the data types we can separate
them in structured data in structured
data for structured data you will
normally use handcraft feature
engineering right so and normally the
best algorithms that perform are
boosting algorithms okay or in samples
methods okay if you don't know what that
is you can you can search it also add
the link here where you can have a read
it's a bit more complete and when you
use deep learning when you have
unstructured data yeah
so you when you cannot come up with what
are the features of this maybe it's a
signal from a from a heartbeat or
something like that or maybe yeah like
an image of course that's the obvious
case text as well
how do you define the parts of a text
how do you find the actual meaning of a
certain word when he's sarcastic or nuts
right that's incredibly difficult so
this is for this is for these cases okay
so I will say in a general way
especially if you're just starting
images texts and signals and you can you
can see this link which is quite a nice
explanation and about the data so a good
performance can be achieved normally
like in a general rule of thumb with
5000 labels sorry labeled data for in
this case supervised learning for
unsupervised we don't even talk about
that because now you're talking about
reinforcement learning and those
actually have to happen in a fake
environment that you can repeat as many
times as possible and now you're talking
about billions of experiments so I'm
talking and supervised learning here
okay and for really to get into human
performance we're talking now about
millions okay now I will say this is
true if you start from scratch this is
not true if you use transfer learning
okay we're going to go a bit what that
is the recommended literature that I'll
definitely go have a read I don't think
is that heavy in in math but it does
have some lineage or algebra in it but
yeah that's that's the book I recommend
you to buy and some trainings of course
my trains anyway so there is a way that
that's their science week and I think
yeah so next that made 29 so prison and
so you can just take a look okay so
we're going to talk now about deep
learning tools
questions not so far
goods
know how we're doing in time but that's
it yeah I forgot about that you put it
here okay
this is a short one so deep learning
tools so deep learning tools there are
several there are many there more than
this you have also cafe MX net etc but
if you are going to start choose one of
these
caris or PI torch well tensorflow as
well but then you can use carrots with
tensorflow at the backend tensorflow
is sort of the what is it what is the
phrase nails and bolts something like
that if you actually want to build that
for something from scratch so for
example the other day I was researching
some type new or not researching but I'd
I tried to build something to translate
a research or idea into a neural network
and of course it's not implemented so I
had to use tensor flow for example right
but for any other sort of standard use
cases I will say go to chaos or PI torch
okay in for today we're not touch on
cars so why are we going to touch on
Keros basically one of these one of
these explanations basically because
it's very popular and it's of course
that's like okay you're all going in the
popularity trance right now but that
means also there is a big community
behind it so there are issues you can
search there are gonna be less box of
course because it's open source or every
open source of course and also not on
persona has bugs but so there's a large
community and especially recently has
taking a has taken a nice boom with the
tensorflow background in the backend so
basically as we're gonna do we're gonna
do scare us with a tensorflow back-end
you could also use torch for example so
we're using also like the top two right
so also this is basically the community
contributors Forks issues and activity
right and if you start using it don't be
afraid of submitting issues huh like if
you check issues some issues are like
really a question maybe that the the guy
that made it didn't thought about it and
you can help the community
by doing that so visualization about
this what I like this is the tensile
adjust comes with it right so it has a
tensor board where you can just see how
your models are training you actually
can see it real time how the models are
training the loss curve house is
performing so you could stop it for
example if these stakes I don't know a
couple of days or something like that
you can also compare with other runs
that you have made and also has I don't
know if you guys know what word
embeddings is but it also has the
visualizations for this so it's very
complete from pi touch sites you have
visited which I haven't used but it's
far far more customizable but of course
comes with a penalty that world you have
to do it okay so in general in general
one of the things that I will say is
that why do I sort of I think pi touch
is gaining a lot of popularity yesterday
I was in a deep learning meet up by here
in Amsterdam and they were using a PI
touch for example there was a in the
University so research but for me is
like tensorflow I mean the people that
is behind there's a flow I mean it's
Google I mean you know they're releasing
these things like crazy since they took
over right now I mean let's what 1.4 I
think I don't know a year and a half ago
now I think they are already 1.7 or
something like this they're releasing
like crazy and and it's getting better
and better and better and you're gonna
see for example for the choice
especially for the transfer learning
case how easy it is to have these tensor
flow in the backend it's just it just it
will just work of course there's also
some some issues like everything ok so
this is gonna be the first exercise I
think this is what you were waiting for
so so of course if you already had
Karras enters the flow installed you are
gonna be able to run this if you didn't
then it means that there's an
environment file there on the repo and
using an echo
you basically will have to run the
command sorry
Conda and conduct and creates - F
environment environment llamo so that's
a bit maybe a mouthful but basically so
let's say for example not projects you
cannot see that yeah so there's the
environment file you can see there right
now you would do something like condor
3:8 if not so if you don't have
experience with with anaconda maybe ask
your buddy in the side i can also help
you as well and so i'm gonna i'm gonna
leave you guys to work on it let me see
what what what I wrote in the schedule
hopefully we're in time and for others
please raise your hand people that don't
have laptops and questions it can be
about anything
what is the actual impact where have you
seen it used where have you not seen use
what are you gonna talk on San Francisco
what is these other other LST aims
recurrent networks so I can talk to
while other people is working on it so
let's check the issues first yeah and I
see some faces that I know you know how
to create a virtual environment so help
the others I know I know you let me
write it down but let's see let's see if
there are some issues alright
well nothing okay so no questions good
Oh first Ronde sale first so you can see
actually like nice images because if not
you're gonna get any like in your face
so basically this notebook is very basic
so if you already like if you take it
like really quick just go to the next
notebook you have the link at the bottom
of the of the other notebook but this
basically will try to teach you how to
bail the model how do you add these
so-called layers right so try to try to
run it if you cannot install and you're
sick of it because it just doesn't work
and you have because you have a Windows
computer or something like this which is
normally normally the reason so you have
some links here where you can where you
can read maybe you read something about
it and then you ask me a question and
you have all other links about the
layers
yes so four carats are you gonna see in
that notebook once you create a model
you need to compile the model so you
cannot sort of change it on the sort of
on the fly by torture allows you to do
this yeah so fighters are so in a sense
you can a layer train then add another
layer train without this compile
compilation
yeah
so the lair is a collection of neurons
which which which are so if you have if
so this this will be a layer this this
yeah yeah so you can have you can have
for example this is called
somebody knows what these layers are
called you answer yourself
so yeah fully connect the layers yeah so
then you can have for example a drop out
layer which is said and then I will need
to explain what drop out this but
basically you put sort of a egg I will
say a gate which randomly throws away
some of the some of the lines so for
example that's because you want to it's
for the reason of overfitting so you
don't want so for example this one is
learning something very very specific
and it comes from certain part of the
image now let's say the image change a
bit and this doesn't fire anymore so
it's really it's overfitting on that
particular image so you want to sort of
throw their weight sometimes such that
other neurons learn to compensate so
that's that's an example of a that's a
drop out layer okay then you have for
example or all activations are also
layers you can see them they're also
there then you have for example an LS TM
layer so an I won't explain what lsdm
but you can basically have your lsdm
layer and there's a whole machinery
going on and you say well after my
Elliston layer i want to connect the
outputs to so a fully connected one for
example i don't know you can say one
more that is their convolutional for
example right you have a conf yeah so
for example you have your image we're
gonna use that right and now it comes
into a convolutional layer so you just
throw it in like okay this will do just
the convolution
and this sort of and then you say okay I
want another convolution and then maybe
you are wonderfully connected
yeah so it sort of Heights this
machinery of each of the and I'm not the
same in the sense that how this works
right but in the sense that their stack
but but if I if I would for example if I
say okay what is in here yeah so these
are recurrent for example this is
actually an extended what they connect
to themselves in previous previous step
so it that's what I like a bit about
carers so you know the theory you know
how they work and implementing it is
yeah yeah but this is also sort of I
will say a bit of a problem right no
because people just throw layers and it
and doesn't really know why right so I
think I'm not sure but maybe there's an
example here yeah I think I have an
example where it is gonna be something
weird there validation is gonna have a
higher score than the training set yeah
so let's say you do you throw these
layers right you because you've read it
somewhere and you find this and then
you're like okay and then you show it to
me and I ask and I ask you what why why
is this yeah so it's because of how
they're one of the behavior of the
layers but so I will say that I like
yours because makes the implementation
easier I do you don't so data scientists
I think one of the I think by now I hate
computers right yeah because the problem
is our computers our problems are not a
theory but anyway so so Cara's makes it
very easy for you
so if you know the theory behind it a
bit it's just throwing it around so for
example one of the things I think I
asked during the notebook you can see
the summary of the model let's let's
let's let's let me show you that
for example let's just start with this I
mean even the simplest I tried to add a
layer and it doesn't work why why it
doesn't work and you have to think about
the concept well because just the
concept of it it doesn't know what
inputs is gonna get so just the concept
of it this doesn't make sense so you can
define your own input layer but then
below I do it caris that's it for you
you just add oh I expect this
I expect this amount of dimensions and
caris will do it for you but you do need
to know it because you let's say you you
you hit this error right the first layer
and a sequential model must get an input
shape or batch batch input shape
arguments yeah sure so you add it and
why what value should be right so it's
because it's is the amount of inputs
that you you're gonna get in this case
we saw this this or two so these are the
inputs so if you see the first hidden
layer here you have input two but the
amount of units it's three so I'm
creating this sort of interface yeah so
it makes it easy for you you could also
define one by one but for the input is
not not necessarily you can also for
example yeah for example this this
question below that's when I catch
sometimes that's sort of my first
question sometimes also for some
interview or something when they say oh
I know deep learning ah good good
so okay so then I asked them I just a
simple
where did why are there nine parameters
okay so yeah and how this how that does
come up to two nine so yeah you're
you're in the correct path that so you
have these two connections right that's
already here what do i I like to draw I
guess so you have these two right and
three so how many weights are there six
so why are there nine yeah somebody said
it the biases and then yeah so actually
each of this is more or less like a
logistic unit right these weights times
the features plus a bias that's where
they come from
okay now when you will implement a
convolutional there are also parameters
and also the question I think you get to
understand when you when you throw a
layer and then you see the parameters
you're able to try to understand okay
why are these some on the parameters
because you do need to know what's
happening in order to do that you could
you could just don't care as well but I
would think you would like to care about
that yeah it depends
yeah so about this these sort of layers
they are they're all there
yes they are all there and there for you
to access and for example one of the
difficulties that I see sometimes when
people try to implement convolutional
layers is the input/output the
dimensions because you need to define
the dimensions it will tell you I this
but I received this and that's a bit I
will say I will think a bit more tricky
for people that are just starting up and
that's because how does that actual
convolution works right so you can try
it I think it's what it's me I think
it's one of the exercises later I think
but you're probably gonna hit this
problem I
hit no no yes I forgot this other other
dimension but so that I've got the
parameter so optimizer is the same thing
they're there for you
they have you back more questions okay
so what we're seeing right now like I
mentioned here on the top this is the
sequential API caris has two types of
api's that I know of
let's say like a sequential and
functional API the sequential LPI is the
easiest it sequentially SPEA api is the
one that yeah it sequential now the one
that is one after the other
okay there is no sort of coming back or
branching and then reconnecting well so
so for most of the no not yeah for for
most yeah for most of the use cases
sequential API is enough given that you
know what the layers are actually doing
like like you said so for example but if
you want to build for example
let's say you want to build this can you
build it with the sequential API of
course not possible right so you need to
do the function on this case is this
actually a model we we use for what
ecology used and built for detecting
anomalies in the heart from MRI scans
for a project sudden you cannot write
you have to use a sequential you sorry
you have to use a functional right but
we're gonna stick with the basic
question for today yeah yeah so that's
research and there's the main knowledge
and tribe just trying and there are
already some sort of older architectures
where they do something similar so they
sort of build on each other right so for
example if I show you let me see
actually it's a good time to see who
should be in the next one okay anyway so
if I show you this for example
oh I don't have it okay
maybe it was loading wait yeah I was
loading okay if I show you this one for
example right
that's Inception v3 I was made by Google
2015 I think at least the paper okay so
if you see yeah
they built on top of each other so these
for example this architecture that you
see more or less than repeats was
already before somebody introduced it
and this has to do with convolutional
and and the pulling from layers but and
then you say okay why don't we start
them together right and then you see
this tail here that looks like that this
is also question I asked sometimes what
is this because everybody talks about
this what is this I guess it is there it
is there what why there's actually this
is not complete sometimes it goes
there's there's there are more in the
back and then it's great right why would
I have two outputs because actually this
is this is soft max so soft max this one
once you want to make the classification
and it's in both places why why would
they want to output the output once we
go to the transfer learning we I'll
answer the question okay let's see I'll
help you out a bit
so the different activation functions
like I said the softmax there is relu
that somebody knows now that because I
started someone had experience why is
there for example the hyperbolic tangent
not preferred over the rail or what is
the problem with a hyperbolic tangent
know how nice yeah that is because that
so so they saw the hyperbolic tangent
has this this sort of look right so it's
flat here and it's flat here so what's
the problem with that yeah this guy you
should talk to a chief scientist that
we're hiring so this is yeah because the
derivative is zero so it means that when
you remember you propagate back and you
calculate the derivative and let's say
for some reason your input goes into
these parts what what is the value that
is going to multiply by zero so what is
going to be the propagation back zero is
it gonna learn anything no and then your
model is stuck that's called the
vanishing gradient problem okay it has
to to two sources one is this one is
this there are other sources and the
other source is actually a solved by
white but I just show you about having
the extra branch by anyway so this one
here yeah that's okay but the problem is
that if you if they go sort of say in
this sense you don't want them but the
thing is here they're in both sides and
that's that's sort of the the problem
because yeah that's the other issue so
when you have a matrix right and you're
multiplying values let's say these
values are lower than one right so
they're gonna go to zero basically right
but if they're very big or they're
bigger than one want to multiply they're
gonna end up in this area
right now so they're gonna end up in
this in here which this does not have
the problem that's the other that when I
said the two sources one is the source
is the activation function and the other
source is the multiplication because in
system so recursive there's going to be
a lot of sort of multiplication of
weights to get to that one so if the
weights are lower than one they're going
to tend to zero and they're going to
banish the same way that this makes it
vanish so that's the other source or
they can be bigger than one and then
they're gonna explode so they're do you
have two problems the vanishing gradient
problem and exploring gradient problem
and the so that's why yeah yeah but then
yes yes yes so that's when you have what
is called leaky relu you can see did you
look at your activation functions now
liquor a loop so it defines it defines
sort of an angle in here there are there
are many ways to deal with that but the
result for example takes away those
those zero tails but good questions
okay so this is what I said about the
compiler remember who asked about the
difference between PI torch and right so
it compiles so I say you know use the
optimizer I Adam here's what you need to
know sort of okay what are the
activation functions how do they work
why why is it binary concentra P right
depends on what you're gonna calculate
so for the next example for example
we're going to use I think cross-entropy
which is for more than one class and if
you really want to get into the details
then you do the config which is helpful
as well
and notice this one notice this
parameter trainable so it has enough to
turn that weight to freeze the weight so
say you know I like this I like this
value of my weights right now so I want
to freeze them I don't want to optimize
these weights so that's basically what
we're going to do in the transfer
learning okay so in here I created these
data set which is not linearly separable
okay so basically I create the typical
test set now also by default
caris comes with what is called
callbacks if some one of you is already
familiar with what a callback is but
basically is that a certain point in
time during the training is gonna call a
function and then it's gonna do
something with that so Karis already has
for example for doing the tensor board
already has it for it because you need
to save it into some locks how your
training is going so Karis already has
that so you send it as a callback and
it's gonna sort of save the accuracy
that is having during training time in
that lock and then tensor board is just
gonna pick it up in real time and it's
going to update their figure that's
that's how it works but you can say any
type of callback so this
I created my own callback you can see it
in the utils
in the utils module in here so how it
looks
should be somewhere there so it's this
one so now it's yours you can use it no
problemo and you add it as a callback
okay now if you see you once you compile
you use the model fit alright very easy
and then you just send the training data
the number of epochs so the number of
epochs is the number of times you're
gonna go through the whole data set so
for example let's say you're not you're
not shuffling your data set when you
choose a badge let's just say you
separate in five batches so you say okay
I'm gonna say I have I don't know a
thousand observations and I make a make
batches of 200 okay so then I have five
batches and each five batch that's an
epoch yep because you're gonna see this
in the in the when you read stuff right
so an impact is not it's not each
optimization time it's optimization step
is once you go through the whole data
set so in this case I have a batch size
of 100 I don't remember how many
observations they have and I'm running
at any pox okay if you see also out of
out of just very simply you have
validation split so on training time is
going to separate in a validation so
it's gonna sort of optimize for certain
part of your data set and for the other
one is Janis is gonna calculate whatever
score you you want to calculate in this
case is accuracy so that's why if I put
variables one in here for example right
you can see this validation stuff so if
I wouldn't add that right I don't have
it it uses the whole data set to Train
yeah that's why alright so there you see
it in this case and that doesn't do
anything but I don't want but anyway so
okay so then you have the curves let me
just close okay but this is this okay so
you're gonna have these curves which are
the basically learning curves so in this
case I'm just gonna write okay so in
this case if you see now I define
normally you will define the model like
this like just in one in one go so
before I did it in certain different
cells just to sort of take you through
it but normally you would do it like
this
okay so also these curves that are here
are are made by this function I made so
this also yours you can use it and then
you have what is called these the
learning curves so this in this case is
the accuracy so how many times I'm
guessing the class correctly all right
and then you see the curve for
validation set and training set during
training time okay so and then the last
right so in this case we said I think
binary entropy cross entropy and we have
the loss function here how is it
behaving so when I see this right so
it's not flattening out so it's it
appears that still it's going to go down
so you probably need more epochs in this
case right you also might see something
maybe maybe we can see it here you
Abbadon I'm gonna show you the answer
okay that's fine okay so now what I did
is not really expected so sometimes you
might see really sick SAG function sorry
curve so something that it is going down
for example I don't know if it's gonna
happen with this because the data set is
sort of pretty prepared but yeah also
because of the amount of classes there
not many you might see something for
example let's say the accuracy that
looks maybe like this
now you might see something like that so
any idea what this might be the problem
this is let's say this is accuracy
so this normally is because remember the
weights get updated every on every batch
so it means that each of these points is
what happened for every batch so it
means your batches are too small right
so it is moving in the correct way but
because your batches are too small
they're not capturing the actual
representation of your data so in
average is moving to a correct position
but it is sort of taking these these
steps where you're not really optimizing
for the data itself but just this this
batch is too small yeah so you might see
this I've seen this several times so
that means just increase your batch okay
so I think we so so okay so now we have
this this exercise too so maybe some of
you went over it a bit already so I want
you so these are two classes of course
you can separate in some other way but I
just wanted you to do to learn how to
add other type of layers so what I
wanted here is just make an overkill
model so model that is just extremely
big for these two classes and it's
something like that so the idea is that
we're gonna create three hidden layers
we're gonna use batch normalization
we're gonna add dropout layers and we're
gonna use Ray Lu and also the hyperbolic
tangent I don't care about the accuracy
about this it's just for you to actually
make it run okay so what batch
normalization is that's normalization
layer so yet another layer it's
basically you have your sort of your
your input layer or I don't know
something and then you have your another
hidden whatever something like that
right and let's let's put it here for
example let's say you have these
connections
something that is right and then these
sorry the activation of these neurons
right it's going to be multiplied by
these weights and they're gonna enter
the each of the neurons and then they're
gonna be squashed or by this nonlinear
function this can be reloj which can be
the hyperbolic tangent okay so for
example when you use the hyperbolic
tangent like like my friend here
explained this this sort of are a bit of
a problem there's another problem with
but I'll mention in a bit so you will
like the inputs to this to be around
this this area so what what the
Batchelor molestation does it does what
you do when you in a linear regression
when you scale your features exactly the
same thing it does exactly the same
thing but it does it in the middle of
the layers so if you add a Bachelor
molestation layer in here you basically
rescale this such that for the pencil on
the type but let's say such that it has
mean 0 and variance 1 and then it throws
them into into here such that you do
have the data around that point
independent so it's exactly the same
it's per feature so now the feature is
each of these right so it's exactly same
so it's like forget about that you had
that and now you have sort of let's say
this is the input and you are normal
you're sorry scaling your features yeah
so this achieves this right because you
don't want it to be extreme but what
other things why do you scale linear
regression well I said that was not
gonna explain basic stuff of machine
learning but why do you scale it
why do you scale your features again we
can be it doesn't matter normally
normally I will help you out no ok
why I see you uh no okay so so normally
you scale it because two reasons if
you're using regularization right so the
regularization penalty the coefficient
is the same for all features right or
not it's just a term which is like this
it's alpha is that right its weight in
the index independent so if you don't
scale them this value can be very big
for some features or can be very small
for some others which means the
penalisation term will be huge for
things that are scaled big and for
skills that are there are actually small
then this will be quite small right so
the penalisation term so there's another
reason and the reason is also the last
function and that's what that is related
to the to the neural networks so if you
have let's say you don't do
regularization you still want to scale
them because when you're doing a
gradient descent we have what is called
the learning learning rate right we
already know right so you have and we
also introduced it in the equations so
you have your weight I equal to weight
plus one weight oops
wait I write plus some learning rates in
this case I'll call it off as well times
the gradient of your last function on
the weights right okay so the is this
learning rate in the independent yes
right it is the same for every feature
so it can be if this turns out to be
proportional to the value of the weight
of the value of the feature for example
then it means that I'm taking really big
steps and one of the dimensions are the
features and really small steps for
others so I might be looking in really
honest
what isn't anisotropy or not not in a
symmetrical way
right and that's when you see these
figures that when you normalize then you
have this loss function that looks like
concentrated circles I mean everybody
has seen that picture really so it's the
same thing for neural networks you want
to do that as well
because also your learning rate gets
applied in the same way right there's
also a derivative there okay we're doing
a bit short on time okay I'm just sort
of kind of paste it and explain really
quickly please keep the questions coming
if we need if I need to skip something
in that's fine I'll also be around so
can also ask so right so these will be
more surrounded a way to to add these
layers right so we have here with the
fine first sequential right we start
with that start fresh
then we add some batter normalization
and we can give it a name you can also
put it without the name then we then we
yeah what is the input shapes like we
said before the input shape is 2 right
and then the first layer has 30 units
the second layer has 10 units and that
third layer has 3 units right and within
each of those layers I add a batch
normalization what I said before then I
define the activation function if you
see the activation function is no longer
inside the dense layer as before you
remember you see how I gave it in the
dense why is it not there anymore
yeah because the batch normalization
right needs to happen before the
activation function right because of
what I just explained ok
and then the drop out would basically is
what I explained about dropping some of
the
actions in order to not over fit and
then you can just run the same I don't
know what was the accuracy of the other
more or less but the batches are smaller
or the other right
yeah so this is the batch size of 100
its microphone full compressed yes yeah
exactly
there's not known yet exactly yeah yeah
yeah you can build also a network
without without activation function they
will just explode but yeah so that was
the story like you go to the initial
papers that's where it starts
just connections just connections like
okay yeah whether you're talking a
decade sir yeah okay sorry
so if you see for example we added this
super overkill and then I think now I
have the same 100 bad choice of 100
ebooks of 10 10 epochs I think even we
could do it with 6 or something maybe
even 5 and see how much takes and then
this should already outperform the other
one that's already point 8 right and
this one is take like that so okay I
have to move to the to the other one
because we're a bit behind schedule
actually lots so I will try to run a bit
faster it ok ok so we learn what we
learn in the previous notebook so we
learned basically how to add layers to
model right where do I find these layers
where is the documentation where I can
read about it how can you let's say tune
it yourself you can add the activation
function within the layer you can add it
yourself
if you want to introduce batch
normalization
we saw what button realization does we
saw what dropout does you know in a high
level but we did see de so it's now just
about you reading a bit about more about
these layers and okay this might be
useful this not because you also have
you say convolution for example but then
you go to search for it and then you
will find one dimensional convolution
it's there you I think you saw it in the
layers two-dimensional convolution treat
them and so what does it mean what is
the difference between them so that you
have to read about a bit about about
that okay so this is basically in this
case digit tasks in this case I also
have this one which is actually a pretty
hard data set this one this is the C 410
data set is there for you just out of
the blue you can just build on top of it
it's pretty difficult it's not an easy
data set but just for sake of showing
right now everything should run if you
just uncomment this one so it's just
there for you okay
so first what do we need to do so we're
gonna prepare the convolutional layer
right so normally you will say okay I'm
having these inputs so I need to have
like a one dimensional structure in
order to have my inputs in the case of
convolutional net words you don't write
because you got that's actually what you
want you want to take advantage of these
channels so in this case what I actually
doing here if you see I reshape the data
such that yeah this is this is the
amount of data and this is a 28 by 28
image it has a single channel if you see
that data the data the beginning had no
channel yeah yeah because it's just a
single so by the folly which said like
that but if you want to use this sort of
2d convolution that we're gonna use
later you you have to add this channel
if not it's just not gonna work it's
gonna tell you expected this extra
dimension and it's not there okay so we
also need float float numbers and if you
see what I did is I also rescaled the
pixels
to be from zero to one so far so good
okay so now the idea is I know at it
[Music]
yeah so in this case what I'm doing is
adding in sequential starting with a
sequential then I add some batch
normalization the same drop out now you
see the difference now we have this
convolutional layer and it's easy as
that you just add it to it now the
difficulty a bit is to see about these
the kernel size the number of filters
that you have so the number of filters I
won't explain convolution because it
will take us the whole whole session but
it's basically you go from 3 channels to
32 channels that's what the filters are
so there are 32 different kernels that
are gonna be applied in your convolution
if you didn't understand what kernels us
is but it's basically just so a smaller
neural network that is going to go
through your image yeah so you're gonna
have this sort of not very deep right
you have 28 by 28 by 1 channel and then
I'm gonna convert that in this case by 2
TIPNIS of 32 and what the kernel size is
is basically I'm gonna form sort of a
square of 3 by 3 and then that is going
how am I going to move across my image
that's the convolutional part and what I
use you use an activation also of relu
and border that's how when you hit the
borders of the image so for example if
the size of your kernel does not it's
not a multiple of the size of your image
it needs to make a decision do I stop do
I pad it that's that's basically what
this does so just there are different
options
so this one for example just stops when
it hits the border did I already create
this okay and then you have what is
called max pooling so where the
convolution does it multiplies this
kernel for the image right so let's say
I have a 3 by 3 and it multiplies so I
still I'm still gonna have this 3 by 3
and then what it does it says okay I'm
gonna do something with these 3 by 3
matrix to get a single number and that's
what it's called pooling max pooling
will
I get the maximum value of that can be
average pulling and means it makes an
average depends and then once you finish
that now you now it's gonna start to
connect to the dense layers and it does
need a one-dimensional one so that's why
we have the flattened there so basically
it gets this very deep this clays 32
channels and then I guess yeah and some
dimensions I don't know exactly how many
right now maybe seven seven by seven and
then it will basically flatten all that
in a single array and now it's ready for
the dense layer okay and that's when we
add this dense layer and then we see
this already so as a homework or later
you can ask me again for the convolution
of one why why are they three hundred
and twenty questionnaire so try to
figure it out the bits not that you can
bug me and then I will answer you
I know how much these thinks much so
okay so what we did here you see very
easy
we added layers right we added what we
celebrate The Bachelor Malaysian the
drop out were more importantly with the
convolutional one so the convolutional
one in this case is 2d because it's an
image in 2d
there's also 3d okay because you can
also have known by a race of more
dimensions of course right so that will
be sort of a video okay so if I actually
run this with the difficult datasets I'm
gonna get around I think I get around
this this gate goes very good like
almost 90 percent accuracy but if I run
it with a difficult one maybe I should
leave it running just to show you I get
around 30 percent okay with this
overkill model let me on seconds let's
just do that hopefully it just runs
according to me it should but like a
colleague set
what is it the supposition is the mother
of all fuck-ups there you go my
vocabulary is not that good yeah so I
think what is missing here is this tree
Oh 28 of course now the size of the data
changed the digits are this is what I
mean that the other dimensions are
always the problem once you understand
it so that the size of the image is
different for the other data set so I
have to change it that's basically so
before I had twenty eight twenty eight
one channel now it's 32 32 three
channels so I will leave it running a
bit so now let's move to the most
interesting one and also because we're
mostly out of time but I think the next
one you're gonna have fun once you get
to your house you prepare some pasta or
something ok so let's see so we're gonna
use the same data set okay but I'm gonna
talk to you about pre-trained networks
what does it mean a pre-trained network
so a pre-trained network is it's an a
quite complicated network that a
university or Google or somebody else
did already and they put it available so
they wait they are available that's
that's main the main sort of part the
weights after training these very
complicated models are available to you
all these are available to you ok so in
this case we're gonna use I believe
model net why do I choose that basically
because it will not take you that much
download it and it's also pretty good so
if you see inception v3 I show you
already it's extremely complex it's
crazy right
this is convolution average pool max
pool concatenation dropout fully
connected and soft Max and then is all
that stuff so imagine if you have to
train that on your laptop now it's no
bueno
definitely so so it's great right if we
already have the weights and I will show
you why so this is mobile net this is
the one we we're going to use and it has
also all this complicated stuff
all right you can go through it if you
want so if you seekers already has a
whole module for it
mobile net you can also replace this
with Inception if you want it just
inception is a bit heavier so it will
take you a bit more and what I basically
did I said I look at the type of classes
that this learned to classify so this
this model are available to you was the
model that it was trained with the data
set of image net which is a thousand
classes so it should be able more or
less recognized astonishing claim so I
went into the type of classes and I
choose one you just download a picture
from from Internet so yeah so I don't
want this this one okay why I don't know
I'm a scorpion I guess I was biased and
something but anyway so for me this
image I mean it's I would say it's not
extremely difficult but the tail
especially out it bends with the
background I don't know anyway so if you
see we already have the model right we'd
loaded the model here which is basically
this line mobile net which image eight
and then we just basically adapt this
image to the inputs it's just basically
this land they said this is what is
doing and it's gonna predict and there
you go scorpion 99% sure you know what
this means right
this means that you can use it you can
you can come up with a brilliant idea
and it's there already you don't need to
train it of course it has to be one of
these classes okay so now comes the
interesting part right because now
you're bound to the classes that they
train it for but now let's say you have
this brilliant idea I want to detect I
don't know for example I have a problem
with choosing glasses they're all ugly
so you want to say to filter them if
they are good or not and you want to
have somebody that labels and I want to
adapt this to the tech that's how do you
do that I think we're running out of
time
what's so in this case I didn't do with
the glasses but now I
want to do it for these datasets the
same that I said that we was really
difficult before so what I'm going to do
here is what this is doing is actually
creating a put them in on disk it's
putting the images on my my disk in a
directory way so because normally this
is the way you're gonna have your data
right in actual files not not by carats
giving you the prepared data set so
that's why I want to make it more
realistic so this is more less so this
basically prepares it for you okay it's
gonna take a bit I think
but let me make sure so now if I go okay
so Alyssa Tory created it
so you can see yeah so right now it's
creating the training data so basically
you just need to separate your files
like this you you you point to a file
and then each of the classes you put the
name to the directory and then inside
you just put your images it doesn't
matter what name you give to the images
so now what this is going to do okay
give it a look I'm gonna kill this one
okay so I have no clue why he's taking
so long
okay I'll stop okay hopefully it did put
already some of them yeah okay so there
is our David Schneider so they are
something inside okay so now what I'm
going to do instead I'm going to load
but I'm gonna add this this flag which
says include top false what does that
what does what does do is that it will
give me the whole thing with the weight
but it's not gonna give me this little
part here why because that's the part
that classifies remember we talked about
these hierarchical features so I'm gonna
get the hierarchical teacher features
from everything that was trained but
it's not gonna give me the other let's
see here so if you see here five minutes
so you see there's no softmax anymore
right so now what do I do now what you
do and I have to probably hurry up is
adding myself
first what I said right you make those
layers not trainable you freeze them
because well we completed very very
expensive for you to do that so what I
do here is basically add them so I I
basically sent the base model which is
the one we just loaded and then I add a
pooling I add a dense layer to make
these connections and then the final
upper layer which is a soft Max and
basically I only have three trainable
layers instead of having 22 and 22 which
are quite complicated so now if I do
this I compile it now let's categorical
cross-entropy of course I'm not gonna be
on time on this I think so this will be
a way to get it from the from the file
so this would be c4
[Music]
so I want the image to be rescaled so
that means it's gonna be multiplied by
this value and I believe that's all I
need now I'm gonna send this I'm gonna
read from from the file a batch size of
50 and I know that my my model that I
loaded receives 128 by 21 28 so I don't
have to parrot the images this is going
to do it by itself
I believe this oh I see I see
let's see so here what I'm going to say
to it is that pop up zero zero zero okay
let's just do this right
so it went and found the ten classes
with forty-eight thousand images right
but they're not loaded in memory that's
very important it's not not loaded in
memory so now when I train it sorry
Vincent
let's see yeah just one more so
basically I define you know the number
of epochs that I want and the steps that
I want in the oh yeah and I need to put
this one more and that's it yeah
so now what I'm actually doing is
getting the data from disk and doing
these changes x 1 235 doing the padding
for us already
you can also augment the data by saying
I want to also write 8 randomly or zoom
in or zoom out randomly so the great
advantage is this that you read from
disk right you don't have any memory and
you also have the data augmentation in
preparation already for you this is a
and n for lines of code
alright so cares is extremely extremely
easy and I would advise you to increase
maybe the number of epochs and you see
these candies because you're using this
architecture it can get up to 80 percent
with the other what we had what is it
the overkill model it gets to 32 percent
or something if this is because we're
leveraging and these scales mobile nets
weights and with that
I guess one minute in time Thanks
[Applause]
you